on this episode I talk about wine reddit
and becoming a YouTube sensation
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is the askgaryvee show episode 11
Steve can you give me a 111 hey guys
super excited for episode 11 fun fact
I'm number 11 11 is worn by the sleeper
last pick that you should take in your
fantasy draft this year Jeremy Kerley
he's going to have a big year chip asks
if you owned a winery in Napa
what would your left jabs look like chip
thanks for the question and honestly
I've been reading the feedback thanks
for the critiques yesterday some of you
took it a little too far I mean what I
was really saying from critique the show
was give me compliments not actually
nitpick and find something to upset me
but anyway oh you know I want to start
answering these questions in a different
a little bit of a way and so thank you
guys you guys continue to evolve this
show big shout out to people that have
been tweeting and instagramming the fact
that like it's been interesting to watch
the show evolved from one to ten it is
pretty crazy for the amount of you know
shows I've done and videos are done to
watch it actually have an evolution even
with intention you agree with that
seagull show see you Zak do you agree
with that yes so so to answer your
question I'm gonna answer it in a way
that I hope everybody who's listening
doesn't miss the point that this works
for everybody not just wineries if I was
a winery in California I would actually
make my jabs Wine Library TV let me
explain could you imagine if a winery in
Napa Valley did a show where they tasted
wines from all over the world that were
not from Napa and critiqued them and
gave their thoughts all of a sudden you
started looking at them as an authority
instead of somebody who's just pitching
their wine right now everybody wants to
go the route of like let's show the
day-in-the-life and they take video of
like dropping the crap and and
like tasting that nobody cares about
that they'll care a little bit about the
dog running around and if you teach them
a dog named as Goldie and make more
videos about Goldie they'll care about
that but where they really want and what
you really want is utility the reason
this show exists is this is the next
coming of my ability to give utility
it's I'm giving content that actually is
a little more tangible now it's opinion
so take it for what it's worth but
you've decided you're gonna allocate
your time and I've somehow become
important enough to you or you're
curious enough about my POV and bring
this value value comes in entertainment
value comes in a lot of forms but I
really do think opinion context
information these things are very
powerful and so to answer your question
is I would just review other wines from
the world and give my two cents on them
because then you're leveling up and not
just pitching in the same way that
everybody here instead of talking about
their products or their ebook or their
blog can talk about other stuff
hence look at the structure of this show
these are questions from you that I have
to respond to
thus they mattered more to you you have
to put out things that matter more to
others that's a little bit of my
curveball take it for what it's worth I
even asked do you respond to posts
tweets emails messages or get your staff
to some people delegate this do you
ivenn one of the single by the way I
selfishly this is a humblebrag question
put on the break
Ivan the thing that I might might have
the most pride in in the world is that
I've responded that every tweet that has
ever come out has come out from these
two fingers every email these two
fingers now the content mister stunwin
here helps me quite a bit to make it
actual English but it could look Steve I
mean you're here and I know you're not a
sellout so let's go I mean like you the
tweets the emails no not that there's
that I already said we know I do get
very nervous that it has to be like my
transcribe but like we had like a lot of
exact thanks for having us like we had
we had a calibration of like early on
you're trying to help me in my limited
adjectives and like but like it's like I
do put like
that's an important part yeah absolutely
it's all the base materials this guy
will never say I just I just have the
sprinkles not even sprinkles I just like
rearrange the plate he turns into
English guys I can't write for [ __ ] and
so at the end of the day it is something
that matters so much to me so I do it
Oh me no assistant no social media
person no Vayner employee that's really
good that captured my voice that was my
fam for nine years
none of that Chef asks what food or
foods have you added to your new
lifestyle that you're enjoying the most
chef once again I went with a different
tactic there is no foods that are new no
we went a different route like who you
saw in the last episode we went to the
supermarket I told them the things I
liked that were conceivably healthy
mangoes
you know shellfish luckily for me I like
everything and so there has been no
auditions
this has been about subtractions arsh
asks how can i converge my vision of
being a youtuber with my parents vision
of getting a university degree there's a
very simple answer
most people say what college did you
graduate from not what was your GPA so
you should easily be able to become a
solid D student or seen or whatever it's
needed to graduate which should give you
the flexibility to become a massive
YouTube sensation Chelsea asks what are
your thoughts about face book banning
like gating soon Chelsea I actually
think this is look I think Facebook Adam
gets I think Facebook is maybe one of
the worst PR companies in the world
they've done so much more good than
people realize they are the gold
standard of the future of marketing
because they do so many things for their
users because their users are their
business and they understand it by not
allowing brands to like gate or like
call like hardcore like actions they're
actually helping brands and businesses
and small businesses understand that
it's not about getting people to like be
rewarded win a free crown if you like if
you subscribe to this show you
understand what I'm doing there Andy
you know win a free crown if you
subscribe to this show that's not gonna
do me any good if you really care about
gold crowns and the amount of people
that built their fan bases on YouTube
excuse me on Facebook in two thousand
nine and ten by offering free iPads was
insanity because those were Apple fans
they weren't them your cereal so I think
Facebook once again is making a hardcore
move that is actually helping the users
and the businesses Greg asks your
thoughts on reddit not social media or
do you find it useful
Greg Reddit probably sits firmly in like
one of the three or four places on the
internet that I underachieve on and wish
I did more with historically and spent
more time with you know I I don't spend
as much time in the reddit community as
I should Steve's a huge huge huge fan
huge huge fan of Reddit and as Steve
became a bigger part of my life and
somebody I cared about it actually
quietly made me check it out more we
just did an AMA with my book we're
trying to do one right now for social
media or social media
yep our social media so we're gonna try
to do that in September I got an email
my inbox you know you've been asking
this man my fault do I find it useful
the question is are you asking me as
Gary the human being do I find it useful
the answer is not that much because I'm
not taking advantage of that amazing
world that that's been created there do
I find it useful as a marketing tool I
have looked at it that way and feel like
it's a very interesting place because
that community is very solid you don't
want to jump in in spam read it's done a
nice job creating some advertising
structure that I think is consumable to
the community and good for the brand's
it's up to the brands and the creative
shops to make it reddit II and I think a
lot of people struggle with that but if
you understand the slang the lingo the
vibe of that community and you can play
in that space I find it useful as a
place that business can be done but
business 2020 which is really respecting
the community or you are going to get
annihilated thank you my friends for
watching episode 11 of the askgaryvee
show my question of the day
is very simple what are you doing this
weekend thanks so much guys for the
first couple of weeks of this show as
many of you know because this is a very
hardcore group haven't really started
the big promotion yet of the show I'm
going away for two weeks coming up I'm a
little bit scared that you guys are
gonna fall off while I'm gone but it's
the last two weeks of August and you
should be spending time with your family
and chilling out because that's what
happens in in America inspired by Europe
and I kind of expect the Iraq to
probably make a mixtape of the perverse
11 shows that was me basically telling
him to do that and I will be back with
vengeance you keep asking questions I
will keep trying to answer them
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching the king today and talk
about little old ladies luck and being a
great right hooker